es momento de hablar de los temas de
salud o con Mario Romero salamar Buen
día para ustedes Buenos días Angela y
vamos a empezar con la que podría ser
una buena noticia para los pacientes en
Estados Unidos una farmacéutica anunció
que decidió bajar el precio de su
insulina si la noticia llegó la semana
pasada por parte de la farmacéutica el
Lily vamos a revisar su comunicado donde
se comprometen en reducir un 70% el
precio de sus fármacos de la insulina
para que cuesten un máximo de 35 dólares
al mes justifican que dan estos pasos
para facilitar el acceso precisamente a
este fármaco que debido al complejo
sistema sanitario del país como Estados
Unidos no no tienen acceso en muchas
personas que no tienen acceso a este
medicamento de forma asequible Además
así el Lili se alinea a una política de
la presidente biden que quería
precisamente esta reducción de precios
hasta un 35 35 dólares mensuales para
todo el mundo no logró aprobaron el
congreso solamente para los pacientes
que están incluidos en Medicare que es
para mayores de 65 años entonces bueno
empezamos con esta noticia que promete
ser una un cambio en el mercado de este
fármaco el acceso a la insulina es un
problema en el sistema de salud como el
estadounidense No claro y además la
insulina no es un fármaco opcional para
las personas que tienen diabetes no si
no se toma no se controlan los azúcares
el azúcar en Sangre y aumentan todas las
consecuencias de esta enfermedad en
general los seguros médicos la incluyen
pero en Estados Unidos el seguro médico
depende un poco de cuánto puedas pagar y
eso hace que haya más de 31 millones de
personas que no tienen acceso según de
lancete a ningún tipo de seguro médico
por lo tanto que si desarrollaran
diabetes o tienen diabetes no acceden a
la insulina y además Hay personas de eso
pagando miles de dólares cada año
precisamente por los altos precios de
este medicamento que han ido aumentando
además en los últimos años hay un
estudio publicado en jama networks que
repasa precisamente el alza de estos
precios la línea naranja es del precio
de lista es decir lo que recomiendan las
farmacéuticas lo que dicen que cuestan
las farmacéuticas y ha aumentado más de
un 200% en los últimos 10 años desde
2007 hasta 2018 aunque los precios netos
que es el que paga el paciente se han
estabilizado gracias a políticas
públicas para intentar compensar
precisamente estos altos precios sucede
que hay solo tres farmacéuticas que
hacen insulina el illies una de ellas a
ver si pues a raíz de que esta limite
los precios y los baje tantos haga más
competitivo el mercado y obligue también
a las otras dos farmacéuticas hacer lo
mismo
vamos a cambiar de tema y quisiera que
habláramos de un estudio que nos puede
entregar pistas sobre los efectos de la
radiación en la genética si es un
estudio bien interesante publicado en
Science advances el viernes pasado sobre
la genética particularmente de los
perros silvestres es decir no cuidados
por humanos donde en chernóbil donde
sucedió el accidente de la planta
nuclear en
1986 lo que hicieron fue secuenciar la
genética de más de 300 ejemplares y su
principal hallazgo Es que su genética es
muy diferenciada y distinta a los perros
de otras zonas tanto del país como de
Europa en este gráfico de hecho vemos en
unos puntos rosados Cómo serían los
perros silvestres de otras zonas pues
alrededor de chernóbil pero no en la
zona donde la radiación afectó y vemos
que se van diferenciando primero los
perros de la ciudad de chernóbil que
estaba cerca de la planta nuclear y
después los perros de la zona de
exclusión de la zona de la planta
nuclear precisamente de chernóbil es
decir que solo son diferentes en general
sino que Cuanto más cerca al epicentro
del desastre más diferentes eran
entonces bueno la historia además es que
poco después del accidente en 1986 como
decíamos las autoridades lo que hicieron
fue intentar Pues matar básicamente a
todos los perros que habían quedado
después de que los evacuaran a la
población humana en un intento de que no
extendieran la radiación pero algunos
sobrevivieron estos de los que hablamos
son sus descendientes y además los
autores del estudio dicen que es la
primera parte No de una investigación
más profunda que busca entender
precisamente si ese vínculo tiene que
ver con que esos primeros perros que
quedaron ahí tuvieron algún tipo de
afectación genética por por la radiación
a la que estuvieron extendidos expuestos
Perdón entonces Bueno también es
importante además recordar que ahora
mismo igual estos perros que han
estudiado no han estado expuestos a una
radiación alta sino niveles bajos
crónicos de radiación que no son nocivos
de la misma forma claro con el paso de
los años qué conclusiones se pueden
extraer desde este estudio que por ahora
Pues no serán muchos No claro es un
primer paso no es la primera una primera
un primer capítulo de una serie que
Esperamos que se vaya desarrollando por
ahora todavía son pocas porque no se
sabe si esta diferenciación genética es
debido como decíamos a esta exposición
directa de sus ancestros de sus de sus
primeros perros que quedaron ahí o si lo
que ha pasado es que como es una zona
bastante aislada donde no hay no viven
personas por lo tanto no hay renovación
de la población de perros no hay nuevos
animales pues se han interrelacionado
tanto entre ellos que se han ido
diferenciando genéticamente del resto de
perros del país eso también podría ser
una explicación es difícil no entender y
poder aislar Cuál es esta diferencia
sabemos que según la dosis y el tiempo
de la exposición la radiación sí provoca
daño o cambios en el ADN y sabemos
además que este equipo de investigación
precisamente va a publicar un estudio
Dentro de poco que ahonde en esta
investigación que han empezado a
publicar Pero la verdad es que para
sorpresa de muchos Chernobyl se ha
convertido en casi un paraíso en la
tierra debido a que no hay intervención
humana por ejemplo hay un impacto que es
importante que queríamos revisar también
de un estudio que se recoge la
información y ayuda a entendernos cómo
la vida se enfrenta a estos eventos
adversos es un estudio publicado en 2022
particularmente en este caso sobre una
ranas no son sobre unos perros sino
sobre unas ranas son más oscuras según
más cerca de la zona del epicentro del
desastre estuvieron Y esto no es
necesariamente porque la radiación les
hizo cambios genéticos que luego han
trasladado a sus descendientes sino
porque la radiación las protegía de
perdón la melatonina en este caso las
protegía de la radiación por lo tanto
sobrevivieron las que eran más oscuras y
han ido pasando esta característica
genética sus descendientes es decir que
un impacto seguro lo ha habido no
sabemos qué tan nocivo es y sabemos por
supuesto además que a corto plazo por
supuesto la exposición a la radiación es
nociva pero que a largo plazo pues puede
dar resultados muy inesperados que
todavía a día de hoy no tenemos claro y
se están investigando la naturaleza
sabía y fuerte gracias a usted Muchas
gracias Ángela